Transformers.
Attention is all you need!
Transformers beat state-of-the-art,
transformers are better
than anything else in NLP!
Hi!
Are you tired hearing about transformer experiments
and you wish there was higher architectural
diversity when testing on benchmarks in machine
learning, but especially in natural language
processing?
Then congratulations, you found the right
video for you!
Because today we are discussing this paper
that asks a very natural and interesting question:
“Are pre-trained convolutional models better
than
pre-trained transformers?”
From this paper, we will find out how CNN-based
models (whatever that might mean, we’ll
see in a bit), ... so CNN-based models, benefiting
from the same amount of pre-training as transformers,
were found to be competitive or even outperforming
Transformers in certain experiments!
Or at least that’s what the abstract of
the paper says…
Ms. Coffee Bean thinks that in this video,
you will learn something about transformers
versus CNNs, but you will also learn something
about the importance of framing in papers.
Ms. Coffee Bean?
What even makes transformers so successful?
What do they have that other architectures
don’t?
Well, many things:
First, they are efficient because things that
an RNN computed sequentially, transformers
compute in parallel, enabling large training
scales and faster computations on larger datasets
than LSTMs for example.
Second and as a consequence, the pre-train
and fine-tuning paradigm came into fashion
in
NLP, because with the transformer being more
efficient, pre-training became a thing with
language models on larger and larger amounts
of text.
You know, we’re talking about BERT, RoBERTa,
T5, the GPT-family and so on.
Third, transformers enable contextual representations
through self-attention…
Ms. Coffee Bean, I must stop you there on
the "contextual" bit.
Contextual representations in pre-trained
language models were not a first with transformers.
For example, ELMo and CoVE
enabled this already with LSTMs.
And also, pre-training and fine-tuning was
not invented with transformers.
Pre-training was not that big of a thing in
NLP,
but certainly in computer vision, where basically
every CNN backbone was pre-trained on ImageNet.
So… this paper now asks: What if convolutional
architectures can actually perform on par
with transformers, but this hypothesis was
so far mostly neglected and untested, since
transformers took all the attention! (pun
acknowledged, but not really intended).
What if both the pre-training and the architectural
advances happened simultaneously with the
transformer, but that this doesn’t mean
that these two factors shouldn’t be separated
and analyzed independently.
And this “what if?”
question, this possibility,
is what this paper aims to answer by…
just trying it out with CNNs!
Or that’s what the paper says…
There are recent works showcasing CNNs on
sequence to sequence modelling too, but this
study is the first (Ms.Coffee Bean, did you
check?)
to be more comprehensively structured
on a range of tasks and focuses
on the pre-train-fine-tune paradigm.
Or that is what the paper says…
Ms. Coffee Bean, why do you keep saying this?
Well...
Why the focus on CNNs?
The paper says it:
Because their window is smaller than for usual
self-attention, you know...
which is spanning all tokens, therefore they
are faster to compute, not suffering from
quadratic time and memory complexity.
It's only linear.
Furthermore, they operate locally and do not
need this extra construct of positional encodings
forced into the architecture
But this also means that the global context
cannot be captured by one layer only.
In a convolutional network, it is the succession
of layers that increases the context window,
or the field-of-view, to use
a computer vision term.
For example, for a kernel of the size of
two tokens, if the third token would be radioactive,
let's say... in yellow,
it would mean that after one layer, the first
token does't include information from
the third token,
but only from itself and the second token,
but after a next layer, it also contains
information from the third token!
Okay, this is a very interesting striding
choice, Ms. Coffee Bean.
Okay, but if we're going to replace things
with convolutions,
what about attention making the transformer
so powerful?
Well, does it really?
There have been papers recently, showing
that replacing learnt attention matrices with
random matrices does not hurt much and we
do not even want to start about papers replacing
the self-attention layer with an MLP layer
or even with a Fourier Transform!
Ok, so to recapitulate the opponents of today’s
match: the CNN versus the Transformer!
(Or this is what the paper says...)
Let’s go!
In the right ring corner, we have the Transformer,
the well-known champion, the state-of-the
art
in NLP beating T5!!…
Well, at least a T5 replica which is pre-trained
on the Colossal Cleaned CommonCrawl Corpus
with span based masking as a pre-training
objective.
Which in English means, that random spans
composed of more words are masked and the
model must fill in the blanks.
Then this model is further fine-tuned on
diverse downstream tasks comprising toxicity
detection, sentiment or news or question classification,
semantic parsing...
In the left corner, we have the challenger:
a sequence to sequence CNN model!
Which… is basically a transformer architecture
but where self-attention is replaced with
convolutional blocks?
In other words,
this paper is perhaps framed as analyzing
what gains the pre-train and fine-tuning paradigm
promises for CNNs versus transformers,
but it is actually a “we replace the self-attention
with [insert here X]” and this X happens
to be convolutions.
Wow…
I do not know about you, but Ms. Coffee Bean
thought that this paper was something different
than the MLP and FNet paper we have
seen lately, but in hindsight, it is exactly
the same paper pattern, replacing the self-attention
layer with something else, this time with
convolutions.
It’s all about the framing.
Therefore, keep in mind that this paper should
not be interpreted as: what would have happened
if the transformer did not ever come into
existence in NLP and completely different
architectures
would have emerged, but rather as what would
happen if one layer in the transformer would
be not self-attentive, but convolutional,
where all the rest in the transformer
is kept the same.
Ms. Coffee Bean really believed
that this paper disentangles the transformer
architecture and the pre-train and fine-tune
paradigm.
This paper does not really disentangle much...
Okay, rant over, we will discuss this just
a little bit more at the end of the video.
So, self-attention is replaced with convolutions
in three configurations: lightweight, dilated
or dynamic convolutions.
In short, these words mean the following:
A lightweight convolution is when convolution
parameters are shared every other channel.
Dilated means that every other pixel counts
when computing the results of the operation
and dynamic convolutions are lightweight convolutions
but with learnable position-specific kernels.
Yay.
So this “CNN” (in quotes) model is trained
and
fine-tuned on the same data as its
opponent, with the same masked span prediction
objective.
And now, we come to the interesting part:
The authors let the two opponents compete
and well, the results on the tasks show
that there is no clear winner here.
There are cases where transformers are better,
but also many cases where a convolutional
variant is better, so this means that convolutions
also benefit from pre-training.
That's acknowledged.
That's even expected, because even the convolutional
architecture here is almost a transformer.
The authors highlight that convolutions are
not the best choice in tasks that need cross-attention
between two or more sequences, like in natural
language inference where you must predict
the relation between two sentences.
In this case, the cross-attention inductive
bias is desirable.
On the bright side, experiments confirm the
theoretical considerations saying that
convolutions are faster.
The scaling is linear in sequence length and
CNNs are in general more efficient in the
number of floating-point operations than transformers.
In conclusion, the authors themselves say
that there is no clear winner in this battle.
What Ms. Coffee Bean likes about this paper
is, that it shows that there is some architectural
tuning that might be beneficial on certain
tasks.
The point of discussion for Ms. Coffee Bean
is on the last point made in the paper about
disentangling pre-training and architectural
advances.
The authors claim they showed that convolutional-based
architectures can also benefit from pre-training.
And this is where Ms. Coffee Bean disagrees.
So here she puts her point up for debate (she
might be wrong after all): To understand what
“CNN-based architecture” means here,
it also comes down to
what “transformer architecture” means
in the first place.
Is self-attention something of an essence
to transformers?
Is a transformer not a transformer anymore
if one replaces the self-attention with something
else, be it an MLP, a Fourier Transform or
a convolution?
Is it still a transformer without its residual
connections or normalization layers?
When is a transformer not a transformer anymore?
Well, this is a hard question to ask for anything,
like when is Ms. Coffee Bean not Ms. Coffee
Bean anymore?
If you remove the arms?
Or the legs?
Or the eyes?
This is a hard philosophical question
[whisper] essentialism.
For Ms. Coffee Bean, self-attention is not
that much of an essence to the transformer,
but it is this exact flow and parallelism
of information where one starts with a sequence
or rather a set of tokens, then has an aggregating
or mixing layer for all the tokens to produce
new tokens.
These newly produced tokens are then processed
individually and not together.
And replacing the self-attention layer with
a convolutional one, does not make the architecture
immediately a CNN:
It is perhaps a CNN-based transformer.
But if we would name it such, then a transformer
is an attention-based transformer.
What do you think?
What are you allowed to remove from the transformer
to still make it a transformer?
Are you happy with the framing of this paper
where they say that “CNNs” are compared
with transformers or do you think that transformers
with convolutional layers are still transformers?
And... it's terminology: how should the naming
of these things work anyway?
And with all these questions, Ms. Coffee Bean
leaves us...
Okay, bye!